bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt français ce que
l'italie risque de s'enfoncer dans une
nouvelle crise politique
oui ça c'est une perspective 6 aussi de
liaison avec vous m ghisalberti on vous
a retrouvé allez-y oui je disais qu'il y
ait effectivement une crise qui est sur
la table désormais qui est effective il
faudra voir si le président de la
république et réussira à trouver un
nouveau un nouveau une personne capable
de rassembler une majorité stable dans
le parlement italien et en particulier
dans le sénat où il y à une courte
majorité
actuellement pour la coalition du
gouvernement sortant
cette personne pourrait être encore
effectivement dû zapper compter mais
aussi quelqu'un d'autre vous avez un
italien on a un dicton qui se réfère aux
conclaves donc les élections des parents
ont dit on peut rentrer pape dans les
conclaves et en sort et en sortir
cardinal dans le sens que ceux qui sont
les comment dire les plus ressenti comme
un probable successeur dans une dans une
autorité dans une institution
s'ils ne sont pas forcément ceux qui
sont récompensés et retenus pour former
effectivement
un nouveau gouvernement ou pour devenir
un papa effectivement mais disons que on
pourrait avoir aussi le scénario des
élections même si le président de la
république italienne semble vouloir
éviter cette option parce que l'italie
traverse encore comme la france aussi
les difficultés de la pandémie
donc ça serait compliqué d'aller voter
dans ces conditions à une pandémie qui
est fait en italie plus de 85 mille
morts pourquoi giuseppe compter il a été
lâché par alex premier ministre matteo
renzi qu'à retirer on le rappelle un
font partie et aviva de la coalition qui
est au pouvoir depuis le 13 janvier au
calcul politique dans le sens que son
parti est très très très limité en terme
de nombre de parlementaires mais il est
peut faire il est un peu le fasse
plaisir de boire il donc
il pense que cette expérience de
coalition avec notamment le mouvement 5
étoiles mais aussi avec son ancien parti
de parti démocrate de gauche est
terminée parce que ça sonne de son point
de vue le parti démocrate et le
mouvement 5 étoiles en particulier on
déçu leurs électeurs et donc si on
allait éventuellement à de nouvelles
élections ou s'il lui arrivait dans
quelques mois de toute façon monsieur
renzi pourrait avoir la possibilité de
montrer à ses électeurs et au dessus de
deux autres partis qu'ils qu'il a agi de
façon différente qu'il a qui les a
représentés qu'il est prêt
présentée si on va justement vers des
élections vous parlez de calcul
politique c'est le cas aussi pour nous
était conté qui semble tout de même
prendre les devants puisque sa majorité
est plutôt contestées il prend les
devants c'est aussi un calcul politique
de sa part oui je suis je suis persuadé
qu'il s'agit d'un calcul politique parce
que ne faut pas oublier que monsieur
comté n'a pas été élu n'a jamais été élu
mais bon le système institutionnel et
constitutionnel italien permet à une
personne qui a la majorité qui est
soutenue par une majorité parlementaire
des devenir premier ministre
sans être élu forcément mais il faut pas
oublier que justement avant cette
expérience politique monsieur compter et
était inconnu
complètement donc bien évidemment il
ajoute tout son futur politique il n'est
pas encore prêt à aller à des élections
parce que il est en train de créer une
forme de partie mais on n'a pas encore
des périmètres claire de cette formation
politique et donc
par rapport à d'autres parties de partir
est désavantagé sauf pour le fait qu' il
pourrait être effectivement amené à
assurer les gouvernements du pays
un temps que des missionnaires et donc
gérer une éventuelle phase électorale et
qui pourraient le le voir et
l'imposition davantage parce que
naturellement ceux qui gèrent les la
phase électorale peuvent un peu
influencé aussi les les opinions des
électeurs ne faut pas dit il ne faut pas
oublier en tout cas que si on a lié des
élections je pense que finalement le
parti démocrate pourrait s'en sortir
plutôt plutôt bien parce que et les
opinions de deux votes sont bons pour ce
parti sont autour de 19%
il ne faut pas oublier que en 2018 il
avait obtenu 18 19 pour sont aussi en
revanche le parti du mouvement 5 étoiles
qui avait obtenu 32 33 % en 2018
il est il s'est est à 15% actuellement
d'aucun y risquer une débâcle électorale
et peut-être aussi la disparition du
monde politique italien mais tout de
même deux épées comptes etc est en quête
d'une majorité s'il obtient un mandat
pour former un nouveau gouvernement il
va devoir élargir sa majorité si le
parlement reste l'actuelle wii il a elle
devra faire tout le possible donc
conquérir des des sénateurs
constructeurs comme on les appelle un
italien ou renforcer sa majorité mais
naturellement cette opération est très
critiquée par l'opposition mais aussi
par une partie de l'opinion publique
italienne parce que il s'agit un peu
d'une marché d'un marchandage de
de position à l'intérieur
par exemple dans footer gouvernement on
a vu que par exemple le il avait un peu
promis en poste qui serait de
l'agriculture allant de ces sénateurs
responsable qu'on les appelle encore un
italien et voilà c'était stratégie n'est
pas bien venu en italie / ou et des
électeurs et encore les tragédies de la
mort d'annie duke au vide
merci beaucoup à vous matteo à gizeh
averti je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste franco italien